ladies and gentlemen
welcome back i'm joined by david
burtwhistle david welcome to the show
hey how's it going mate very good blue
tick wanker club
in the building what the [ __ ]
happening
reality tv wanky club here we are
[Music]
hey we've joined joined an elusive club
of
people that have known for probably the
wrong reasons known for known for all of
the wrong reasons i think yeah you are
very correct
um so today one of the things i wanted
to speak about a lot of people will know
you from a recent netflix series which
was called
too hard to handle too hot to handle
talk me through that then talk me
through the experience of being on that
because yours
unlike love island which was my
experience on reality tv yours was a
pre-record right you were on that a
while ago and now it's just come out
yeah we recorded it in 2019
in um april so it was a long time ago
and then it came out like a year later
so um yeah the experience of actually
filming it was awesome
like the show itself the product the
production team were
great and the cast were great and
actually had a really good time so like
coming out of it i already thought to
myself like
if this doesn't do very well in the
ratings or anything like i've already
gained
personal experience from this that's
gonna like help shape my life a little
bit
so that was really cool and then yeah
like a year later the show
launches worldwide on netflix and
it explodes and like yeah it just it was
like
number one in 10 top countries for like
a week
crazy yeah
like america uk south africa australia
uh japan italy like
loads of places brazil it just exploded
it was absolutely mental
it's funny that it's distributed
geographically because usually like love
island or big brother or
whatever is broadcast on a
network within a country and that means
that the people that know about the cast
members and the story
lines are geographically quite confined
whereas this situation is
so dispersed you're talking about people
in [ __ ]
italy like america like
everyone everyone knows a little bit but
do you know what i mean
mate it's crazy it's absolutely crazy
there's like
yeah it really is a worldwide audience
you know like people that comment on my
post
and that engage with me on social media
are from everywhere
like taiwan uh korea
russia you know new zealand australia
kenya literally like all over the world
and it is mental to think that that many
people of different origins have seen
my face crazy power and netflix man
how are a netflix obviously they
exploded it was crazy
crazy really crazy they're uh they're a
bunch of beasts
talk to me about what um what some of
the lessons that you've learned then
since either from being on the show or
from uh
coming like it being released and then
you're reflecting
uh upon this kind of ascension into
notoriety
uh i think that the main lesson
that i've learned is
that even if you have massive exposure
i.e a big social media following it
doesn't
mean that you're necessarily making a
lot of money
firstly and it doesn't necessarily
set you up for success um
i think there's this big assumption
that if you've got a lot of
followers then you're somewhat
successful
and although you might have done
something very cool or good
in order to achieve that follow account
um you know it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're actually a successful
business person or you've got all life
figured out or anything like that
and so it was it's almost like we kind
of set ourselves up
because of the way the world is at the
moment to
think that someone who has a lot of
followers is
killing it and they might not be you
know like you have to have a business
you have to
chase it you have to work hard for it
like you know
i came out of filming and then
worked for a whole year to set up my uh
coaching brand endeavor life put
hours and hours and hours and thousands
of pounds into that
and since the show's launched i've like
constantly been thinking like what can i
do who should i be speaking to who
should i
who should i talk to like podcast you
know this is a prime example like
speaking to you today
christopher williamson that's who you
should be speaking to man
exactly you know like speaking to the
right people engaging with the right
things and also thinking like
how can i actually create a business or
how can i have some longevity here
and be smart about this and
that's not something that just happens
like it's the same as any business
effectively
you have to work really hard to make
something happen
you just have marketing so like a social
media
channel or page or whatever that's
really big is effectively just a
marketing platform
and if you have that you might be
terrible at marketing and no one wants
to buy anything off you and therefore
you have a [ __ ] business
so it's um just because you have the
following
doesn't mean that you're going to be
successful
and that is it's interesting it's
interesting
being in the position of before and
after and
now i'm like oh yeah but the things i
want to do no one's going to hand that
to me
you know i'm gonna have to create
everything and work hard and it's
effectively just giving me like a little
bit of
the step up obviously and like i do get
opportunities that i wouldn't have got
before
but you still have to work for it it's
not that things are given to you you
still have
to do the thing you still have to work
hard and
those values that were instilled into me
by my parents
like i can't sit back and post now
because it's an opportunity i've gotta
grab with two hands and
work to make the most of
and um you know it's a privilege and i i
can't
really squander that so i think like the
that's the biggest thing i've
i've learned is that you know before
being a blue tick wanker and before
having a bunch of exposure
you know i was there in the same
position as everyone else thinking oh
that person must be making so much money
and like people throw random numbers
around like our so-and-so
got paid x amount for their campaign
with dinghy and
oh yeah they make this much money and
like i mean some people make a killing
on social media
but it's still a job it's a job it's a
business it's a career and you have to
work for it and if you don't work for it
then you will fall by the wayside people
will not be interested in you companies
will not want to work with you
and if you're not the right person it's
just not going to be very long term for
you
so that's it's been really interesting
to kind of see that
coming from before and after um
so i think like that's definitely a
misconception no i couldn't agree my man
i think i think that um what
people that look at reality tv or the
ascension of celebrity and fame
in 2020 what most people
see from the outside looking in is such
a different world to what's going on
inside and it's
it's [ __ ] cliche to be like oh you
know everybody's got their challenges
and stuff like this but it's it's more
than that
what i really wanted to kind of try and
delve into today with you
is to talk about what gives you
satisfaction and happiness and stuff in
life now and the same for me as well
i'm in a unique position we're both in
the unique position that we've both had
periods where
most of a country or a couple of
countries have known our names and known
our faces
and to a lot of people that sounds like
you've made it right but fame
for no reason like because it is fame at
any cost it's fame for
essentially just existing i'm sure that
you were like great on the show and came
across as a nice guy
but there is probably like 3.5 million
nice guys
out there like that that doesn't
separate you at all
and what this ties into is what you're
saying there about the fact that you can
have a big audience
but if they don't actually connect with
you all you've got is just
traffic like traffic is traffic is great
but if you send tons and tons of people
to a site that's talking total [ __ ] i.e
an account which doesn't have any virtue
behind
it doesn't really care about what it's
putting out there is essentially only
skin deep
then no one's gonna monetize on the back
of it no one's going to connect on the
back of it
like i've said this story before and you
may you may have like some equivalent
stories as well about like
so so many people
all that they wanted to talk about as
soon as i came off love island was oh
man
like you must be [ __ ] you must be
smashing it now there must be just like
loads of birds
and you must just be you're making loads
of money are you are you making loads of
money
and you're like bro what the [ __ ] do you
think this is
like i'm i'm not dan bilzerian
got a blue tick and gone back to my
normal life
like the vast majority of stuff doesn't
change and as you said unless you stay
relevant
nothing it goes away very quickly
yeah yeah you did you're completely
right um
it's interesting it's really really
interesting so i think like
what is what's your what are my values
and how does it correlate well
like people knowing who you are right so
like that is
you know some people throw the word oh
you're famous a bit and i'm like nah
some people just know who i am right
that's it i don't think of it as
anything else
um i don't assume that anyone knows who
i am i
it doesn't matter and um
effectively yeah there's a bunch of nice
guys out there
and that's that's cool and i really just
i'm trying to just dive into who i am as
a human being and um use this as an
opportunity to
to share some of the positive things
that i think i've learned with the world
and effectively give value to people
through social media because like it
honestly
one of my biggest piss like one of the
things that pisses me off the most
is influencers putting up a picture of
themselves
and the caption being some
semi-philosophical half-hearted complete
bollocks that they don't live into
like but like just like a sentence
and it's like sounds somewhat
philosophical
but you know that they do not fully
believe living to and act upon that
thing
they've found that or they've googled
mindful quote inspirational quotes
inspirational quote and then copied and
pasted it man i
i'm totally part of uh team influencer
[ __ ] hatred here along with you
we're standing in the [ __ ]
we're standing in the vanguard we've got
william wallace he's on his horse riding
up and down
hold and then there's me and you going
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're a [ __ ]
but you're totally right man like i said
this
i said it eight years ago when when you
get a platform
of any size any size at all
you should take increasingly seriously
the quality of the message that you're
putting out because
the impact it has has proportionally
gone up
when you have three people that know who
you are and what you do
say what you want it doesn't impact that
many people if you're elon musk
you better be delivering some value on a
second by second basis
because you affect and impact so
many people and that's why as you've
said there when you see
someone who does have a really big
platform and i'm not going to name names
because i can't be asked for the [ __ ]
blowback
but everybody knows like pick your pick
your like
irrelevant reality tv star from the last
15 years and it's probably them
and um like those people like you have a
platform you have the opportunity to add
genuine value to people's lives you
don't need to be a [ __ ] closet
philosopher
about this sort of stuff but you can get
behind causes that actually mean
something
as opposed to just like yet another
advert for charcoal toothpaste
how does the world need that much
charcoal toothpaste i don't know
man didn't i don't think they need any
but apparently they actually need
they need loads so you said you said
some of the things that you've learned
uh sort of about life and satisfaction
and things that make you happy so what
are they
yeah well all right so just i think the
core thing that i learned
is that it's all about human interaction
like your life's all about human
interaction it's about connecting with
people
it's it's it's it's not about numbers on
a [ __ ] screen
like i was it was we were in lockdown
the show came out and i'm sat at home
refreshing my instagram watching my
following account go up and not feeling
a [ __ ] thing
i i did not care and i was so confused
i'm sat there like i should be happy
people tell me that i should be happy
people make a big thing about followers
and how that's important and how you're
successful and i was literally like
talking to my mate thinking mate i do
not it doesn't affect me
the numbers on the screen they don't
mean anything what means something
is human interaction and connection and
connecting with people and impacting
people
affecting people positively like leave
the world better than when you arrive
so for me that it became so abundantly
clear
because we're in lockdown and i've got
this crazy juxtaposition of
the show blowing up social media
exploding
and it being deadly silent outside and
having
um like that kind of period of lockdown
was like my lowest time as an adult
as an individual to how i felt i was
flat
i was demotivated i was just
not happy and i was because i wasn't
able to engage with people
like i'm a social person like i'm an
extroverted person
like i buzz when i'm around
others and when i can connect with
people i'm like and i i like see them
and affect them and
things like that and i'm sat at home and
i'm like
i i there should be that like my life is
changing why don't you care
would you because would you have been
any different would you have been any
different had you've been around people
do you think that you would have
suddenly taken a lot of value from the
followers going up then
i think that really what is the where is
the value that you get like for me it's
it's all right so you know every now and
then people recognize me
when i'm out about yeah but like this
weekend there's a person that
stuck out and there was you know i think
probably i went out on saturday
just in classroom and probably like 10
or so people groups of people recognize
me
but this one woman came up to me and she
was like hey david um i just wanted to
say i'm a really big fan i love your
positivity and
what you're putting out on social media
i think it's really great thank you so
much and i was like oh my god that's so
sweet what's your name
and she told me her name was fiona and i
started fiona thank you so much you
literally just made my night like that's
so sweet of you to come up and be so
humble and
like have that conversation with me and
like that
that meant a lot i could see the effect
the positive effect
that i'm having on her from putting out
content that i
think a lot about um
like that is more impactful because i
can see that person
it becomes real you know so
that's um that's the difference i don't
care about someone being like oh you're
that broke
off that show that means nothing
like to be noticed doesn't mean anything
but to see impact that means something
dude
that's it that's it there so you have
defined the territory as far as i can
see there
let me let me see if i can do a little
bit of sense making from some things
that have been floating around in my
head
and maybe some of this stuff will land
with you so
um the problem that i have with most
reality tv
and i appreciate i'm a massive part of
this problem having been on it
is that people are chosen as the lowest
common denominator
and the lesson that it teaches is that
fame and notoriety by any means is all
that matters
what i mean by that is a perfect example
tommy fury fantastic boxer
worked his entire life to be a good
boxer made his name
by existing as an alright looking lad
with a bit of a tan
on tv for a while his talent
had absolutely nothing to do with his
fame so the decoupling
of talent from notoriety
has removed the value that fame used to
give us
the reason that people used to be famous
is because they've done something
now people are famous for simply
existing
and the problem with that as you've
identified
is that it leaves you with a very very
hollow sensation
because you know that the fame could
have been taken
by someone else had there have been
another david
doing that thing at that time on the
show they would have got the same as you
the same as me the same as chris on love
island all the rest of it
however when you do something which is
both challenging and worthwhile
like grinding away in a business and
putting thousands of pounds and hundreds
of hours into it for a year
or creating uh social media content that
you feel
is a true representation of your inner
logos the way that you
believe the world to be and you hope
that it helps someone else make sense of
it and then they come up and tell you
that is a sense of satisfaction derived
from something
which is closer to your higher calling
and i think
what i really want people to take away
from this is what you said when
you were watching your follower account
go up as just this arbitrary [ __ ]
number
numbers on a screen and had that have
been
had you have got 1.3 million
followers from constantly putting out
like just
amazing content that tons of people
resonated with you would have
first off selected for a ridiculously
mindful audience
that super super aligned with what you
think and what you feel
but also you would be you would feel so
much more
uh close to them because it would be due
to your higher calling
right so this this fame and notoriety by
any means
i think leaves it first off it gives off
the wrong impression
to the people that watch because they
presume that that's something to aim for
i don't don't worry about about what i'm
famous for just get me famous
right like and the problem is a perfect
example of this is like [ __ ]
i think conor mcgregor and elon musk and
kendall jenner
and you know some other person have
probably all got the same number of
followers but they've got that from very
very different
ways like yeah you can't have
one currency that equates multiple
people
from one metric of success
which equates multiple people within
different domains of competence
like elon musk as lovely as conor
mcgregor is
elon musk is worth 10 conor mcgregor's
because conor's not going to [ __ ] get
this
species to mars like but
because people have this now ubiquitous
social currency
that they can use oh david's david's at
1.3 but this other guy that was on the
show is only at 800 that must mean that
david's
[ __ ] 1.5 times as much as this person
you know i mean
like i don't know that's that's just a
conception that i've had in my mind that
like decoupling of
uh notoriety from fame by any means to
actually
trying to bring it back to it being
right be famous for something
want to be want to be someone
you know want to do something yeah
dude that's that's so spot on that is so
spot on you
you've very eloquently delivered the
information in an understandable way
like that that was really that's
brilliant
um and actually that's something that
i'm like you know thinking
thinking now as like post post show
like what is it like i'm asking myself
this question like what is it that
you're gonna do
what is it that you are going to
do to impact and and be known as
because just being known
[Laughter]
who gives a [ __ ] about just being known
it's about doing something so like
already like obviously i'm
um you know doing a lot of stuff in
health and fitness and
that's something i already like have
like i am a coach
first and foremost like i'm a coach i've
been a coach in the health and fitness
industry for 10 years and it's not
something i plan on stop doing
but i'm thinking like what else can i do
to to
to do more you know so you're so right
and it's such a shame that
fame has been decoupled from talent and
and there's so many people with massive
followings that talk absolute [ __ ]
they don't just love it no they know
that we know that they
they don't deserve it and this is don't
deserve it in the purest sense of the
word
and what i mean by that is that there is
literally
large swaths of the population who would
do better with
that platform like when i see people
that are plucked out of the
the the the muck and the [ __ ] feces
and the straw on the floor
in in the the back carriage and they get
brought up to first class
and they get this huge platform and then
they
they squander it with just [ __ ]
do you know what it is that's someone
that could have done something
but instead wanted to be someone and
that that to me
as you but it would appear me and you
agree on like
don't desire being someone desire
doing something and if you can become
someone that people know because you
have done
something that resonates with them and
that you felt compelled to do and feels
like a high calling
that is when those two things marry
fame should be because you have done
something valuable
and virtuous and worthwhile that adds
value and makes people feel better
and leaves the world a better place than
when you arrived
if that's where your fame has come from
[ __ ] power to you
and if someone gets a platform like
yours now and then uses that to leverage
a message
which should have been heard one about
health and fitness
one about living virtuously one about
mindfulness one about being
leaving the world a better place and
when you arrived or what whatever it is
that you're working on at the moment
if you use a huge platform to then
further leverage that message
that it gives you even more returns
again power to you
but if you do it the other way like if
if you don't have a platform and you're
just chasing being someone
and if you become someone without doing
something and then choose to just
spaff it away like just like wasting it
i think it all i think it all comes from
like what your initial intentions are
right like where does this all come from
and a lot of what i've realized in life
is that yeah there are some dead fast
type things that it doesn't matter what
your intentions were they're wrong
but there's a lot of things where
actually
it's the intention behind the action as
to whether it's right or wrong to do it
right so like
let's just take becoming famous and you
just kind of said it in a way there
which
is easy to understand like why do you
want to become famous or why do you want
to be known
is it because you just want people to
know your name so you walk into a room
and people look at you and they go oh
that's girl so you know that
people know who you are because you need
some narcissistic validation
about who you are because you don't have
any self-confidence then you're
completely
void of any like internal happiness
and you just need someone to validate
you every [ __ ] minute
that doesn't necessarily that would be
the real the best
best reason why to become famous or to
be known
but do you want to use an opportunity
to develop a platform in order to
better enrich other people's lives or to
create
change or to share a message because
like truth be told
i did this show because i knew fingers
crossed
it would give me a platform to be able
to do exactly
what the [ __ ] i'm doing now like that
was
it apart from it was going to be a great
opportunity to do something and tell my
friends and have a story to
look back on and be like yeah that was
[ __ ] cool but also
because i was already doing the exact
thing i'm doing right now
before the show and like anyone who's
been following me for years will have
seen
that the exact same content before and
after
and so it's like
why you want to do something defines as
to whether it's the right or the wrong
thing to do
i understand what you mean you it's a
very rare person man
to go into a situation and then like
10 000 x their platform and come out
and still be largely the same person
after that i think that
that's something that you should be
proud of if that's the case if you've
managed to maintain
uh attached to this same
person that you are i think that's
something that you should be very proud
of
honestly the show itself was a good
catalyst for me as an individual like i
went into that show and
they put me in a position to think or
swim and
the good news the good thing was that i
was already like on the journey of
personal development self-development
like i was already talking to a coach
um like a performance coach like a
mindset coach and i was already reading
books and and kind of on that personal
development journey
and then got put into the put into the
position being on the show
and and then they were like okay the
point of this show is to develop better
more meaningful deeper connections with
other people
and i'm like [ __ ] yes count me in that's
like
that's like uh a professional iron man
and i'm saying right this is going to be
a run swim bike
dating show yeah exactly
and i'm there like amazing so like when
there were opportunities
for me to choose to go in
deeper or pull out i took the
opportunity to go in deeper
and that's why i personally got more out
of it out of the experience
on a dating show on a dating show never
pull out david that's the lesson that
we're taking
from you number one
go in deeper go in deeper and uh
enjoy the process yeah
it was it was good and like i personally
got a lot out of it in terms of um
relationships
and realizing that um
what i really want is to be in a like a
happy committed
deep relationship with someone and um i
was just
[ __ ] scared of getting hurt and
that's why i
kind of kept girls at arm's length
because i was scared of getting hurt
and so effectively that the show was a
catalyst for that and made me [ __ ]
very aware of it and then also it made
me so aware how actually like in life
we we don't have the opportunity a lot
of the time to create these
deep connections with people because of
a lot of the things which keep us on a
superficial level it might be that we
have friends because we go out boozing
with them we don't actually know that
who they are properly um because we
never have deep conversations
you know it may be that we float around
from job to job or we're
constantly transient from city to city
or um
we're trying to do things for the gram
instead of enjoying the moment and being
present like
i didn't have my phone you didn't have
your phone when you were doing love
island and you realize that actually
conversations with people sharing things
that
make you scared sharing moments of
triumph and
jubilation they're the things that bring
you together
and like when you get to know people on
a real deep human level
that's when you become closer with
people so it reminded me to put my
[ __ ] phone down
stop watching tv create opportunities in
my life
to actually connect with the people that
matter the most
and to stop putting time into
the experiences which give me little
else other than short term quick fix joy
which don't get me wrong there's i'm
keen on some short-term quick fix joy
every now and then like it's a great
time
i went out on saturday for example it
was [ __ ] brilliant
but it's not something which it really
creates much depth in your life and
that's what a lot of people are really
missing out on is that
is that debt and um that insight
is worth far more than a million
followers
[ __ ] yeah 100 man that's what i said
like at the start of this podcast
i said that having done the experience i
came out
and i was like it doesn't matter if
anything comes off this
when it comes on the tv i've already
learned i've already become a better
person i've already
had a invaluable life experience
so that's you know that was it was huge
and it's yeah
it was really interesting actually so
that was definitely big lessons dude i
mean rightly so as well like
i don't know how many people who
presume this that you go on a day
you go on a dating show and you get
catapulted towards a life of integrity
and virtue because of it but you've got
two two sort of living and breathing
examples perhaps you went in a little
bit more actualized than i did i was a
like lost [ __ ] soul before i went in
and i my lockdown week before my press
lockdown week
i read um the first books into uni which
was the pilgrimage by paolo cuello
and it sent me west sent me totally west
because it was so meaningful
and i had nothing else to think about
other than this [ __ ] crazy book and
i'm having all these dreams about it
and then i go into the villa and they're
like right now float with that girl over
there and i'm
having this semi-fucking existential
crisis because i've just read paula
coyle
the alchemist [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh dude anyone that needs needs an easy
read um
pick up anything by paulo coelho it's
really really good my mom loves him as
well
shout out mom mrs williamson she'll be
um
yeah dude i am i think
gaining that kind of insight is
it there's literally no price that you
can put on that um
and the quicker that people realize that
this
isn't just me and you saying it because
it's convenient
i've got i'm talking to a guy who has
just
gone from essentially relatively zero to
a million and a bit followers on
instagram which to most people would be
like the ascension to the [ __ ]
heavens
and we are both telling you
that doing something is more important
than being somebody
like this isn't part of some [ __ ]
david ike brian rose london real
conspiracy [ __ ]
like i'm not doing this so that we can
keep all of the followers for ourselves
i'm saying this because this genuinely
is the closest
uh proxy to what mean you think the
truth is
the truth will be floating around in
there somewhere it's we're not
perfectly precise human beings but we're
as close as we're gonna get
um let's change track a little bit what
did you learn
or what are your views on
how reality tv has affected
young people's views on dating
how has it affected their views on
dating it's hard to say exactly
based on just reality tv
but i think that it makes people feel
like the thing that matters most is how
you look
because those the shows reality shows
pick
objectively pretty people and so
you know there's this idea that it's all
about your looks and
often they pick stupid people and
so you get this connection between
stupidity and beauty and that can
often influence younger women
especially to not
chase their intelligence and pursue
their intelligence and
their humor and their quirks and their
like the internal beauty of who they are
because
what is mainstream is superficial
is your eyelashes and your nails and
your hair
and your bikini and all of that that
goes along with it
but i'm gonna tell you straight up right
beauty is not the most important thing
buy a [ __ ] country mile and you you
know if you
are just pretty that is all that people
ever see for like you look at a painting
and you're like that's an objectively
beautiful painting
i you know i don't know anything about
his personality i don't know
what the quirks are i don't know if it's
funny like if all you are is pretty
that's all you'll be seen as
so in order to gain depth and the deep
connection with someone and to be seen
as more and
to have those real deep things like i
think that
it's a shame that those are not
encouraged
because actually when guys are ready to
settle down
and when guys are looking for a
girlfriend and
like if you're to be to have that
commitment there needs to be more than
just
beauty and it's it's you know
i think that's a real shame that it
almost discourages
girls to look at those more deeper parts
of who they are
um and guys i don't know how would it
really affect guys
i think it it probably makes them think
that in order to get the girl you have
to be an arrogant ilkan
because that's how most of the guys come
across it's how
producers often try to make you behave
you know this is the thing that most
people don't realize that
in reality tv especially because there
is a limited amount of time to do
character development
the producers the producers look for
people that fit into archetypal roles
so you want the hero the maiden
the villain the dorky one the pretty one
the nerdy one the this the one the that
the silly one
the one that pisses on the floor the one
that does this you know you want like
those are the archetypes and the reason
for that is it expedites
people from having to get past working
out
who that is and allows the storylines to
be the front and center
you don't still want after six weeks of
watching a tv show
you don't still want to not quite work
out whether david
is a buff gym guy or an introspective
philosopher
you want to just be able to go yeah
david he's the joke
david he's the nerd or whatever it might
be and what you get with that
by virtue of that um you get people that
play into those roles on these shows
which means that they kind of double
down and go out to the extremes of these
of these particular caricatures that
they play right they become a
caricatured version of themselves
which is really bizarre to watch um and
quite entertaining as well but
dude i i agree i think you've hit it's
entertaining but it it's super
one-dimensional
it it is one-dimensional you can't if
you're trying to fit into a hole
you're trying to fit into a pigeonhole
then you have to be one-dimensional
because
that pigeonhole is not big enough for
all of the intricacies of your
personality
so and there's no there's not enough
time for the for the show
to get that across that's it and so like
you have finite moments and
opportunities to get across who you are
and especially like i was filming for
four weeks and there was eight episodes
and each one was 45 minutes long roughly
there's no time at all so you you're
only going to get
certain opportunities to display your
depth right and that was one of the
things
why i was like right well these are
opportunities like we had the workshops
on the show and so i just was like i'm
gonna fully commit to this
this is an opportunity for people to see
that i am not just a
guy that works out but actually that
there is
more to me and i i'm lucky
i'm lucky because most reality
shows do not give men the opportunity to
do that
dude i i i haven't i haven't seen it
after speaking to you i'm tempted to go
and watch it now but
i i i couldn't agree more most reality
tv shows
uh select for the lowest common
denominator
do you have a tan do you have a do you
have a set of abs are you going to flirt
with that [ __ ] you over there again
like that yeah exactly and it's it's um
you know reality tv you have to remember
is it's it's
tv it's a show entertainment it's there
to entertain you but at the same time
it's confusing because it's called
reality tv
and there are a lot of them which are
reality
some are kind of more scripted than
others like to be fair mine wasn't
wasn't particularly scripted like we
were put in situations
like we were putting doing the workshops
for example
and um you know they were like okay this
is what the workshop is
but there was very rarely
can you go and say this to that person
like i never got told to do any of that
it was
okay david um don't say that now we want
to get the cameras in and we'll film
that later
you know it was let's get stuff set up
and
the truth is that people need to
remember that tv's tv and
really let's go back from tv into social
media
if you follow someone that you've seen
on tv
and you think that they're cool on tv
start following them on social for a bit
if you like them and then check out what
the actual value of the content is on
their social media
like if you are following someone
and you watch their account and you feel
bad
and you get any negative energy if you
get like
if it just makes you feel jealous or it
just makes you feel
depressed or anxious or that you're not
worth it or whatever
negative feeling you get from looking at
their channel or their page or whatever
unfollow them and if it's me unfollow me
like i want people to be happier when
they leave my page like
that's the point and if someone's just
putting a photo of them in a bikini with
a star
emoji caption [ __ ] them right off
because what is the value in that
they're only doing it for narcissistic
reasons
perhaps there's a plain devil's advocate
with that
there is a place for um
easy-going uh interesting content
that doesn't have to make you know you
might not everybody that's listening
wants to have to delve into the
existential crisis every pulse that they
like no true they can be entertaining
right and there's a lot of accounts out
there which don't give
deep value but they're entertaining and
they're funny like
yeah you know that's the thing that like
absolutely you follow those accounts i
follow a bunch of them they make me
laugh
but that's a positive feeling yeah they
make me laugh
as opposed to people that are just
taking up mental bandwidth for no reason
yeah exactly you know and like what
would you watch on tv
like you watch stuff that makes you
laugh teaches you something
um makes you have a little thing or is
just some light
and that's absolutely cool instagram
because it's photos most of the time
it can fall away from those categories
and into
just look at me
you'll do it as well man like we got to
play the game i always say this
to everyone i can talk about the
virtue of living out your highest
calling and all this [ __ ] and
and and try and delve into sense making
and yeah man it's all about your logos
and speak your truth forward and stuff
but i know for a fact if i post a
topless photo i'll get twice as much
engagement
as if i put anything else up so you
still got to play the game
it's like play the game play the game
you have to play
what's the caption yeah like like this
is my point so like first
trap in the photo first track
yeah put some quality underneath it
whatever
like it and like we both know that
that's the case
everyone knows that sex sells like we're
humans we like having sex
it's cool we're all in the same boat
with that one
but like we we can kind of use that to
again like why are you doing it this
take like links back to earlier like
what my initial point was like
why you do something defines whether
it's good or bad generally there are
exceptions but for you posting a
topless photo like you're a good looking
lad you've got great teeth and a great
body like it's understandable
that people are going to engage with
that but like what do you choose to put
underneath it
is it something like pointless
entertaining and engaging
what i put is life is a beach
live laugh love just be true to yourself
that's what i put because that was the
top result in
uh inspirational quotes
perfectly that's that's it and just make
sure you're on a beach when you're doing
it you know maybe casually walking away
from the camera looking back
into the sunset over the water that's
what's happening man look david
it's been cool man i'm really glad that
we've connected you're you're a great
guy
um it's nice it's nice to hear that
there's a kindred spirit
coming out from um coming out from
reality tv genuinely man i think
the days of you know as much as i love
them everyone that was on the show
the days of the jody shaw lowest common
denominator
like i've pissed myself again like i
really do hope
that the days of that with reality tv
are gone um
i hope that people have had enough of it
and if we've reset some people's ideas
today about what is valuable
like you want to do something not be
someone you want a connection not
not followers like if that's um
reset some people's
uh ideas of what is valuable and
virtuous
and worth pursuing mostly in life then i
think we've
it's been 45 minutes well spent bro so
let's add to your
existingly massive online presence where
should people go if they want to follow
you online and what's your website and
stuff like that what do you want to plug
yeah if you guys want to follow me at
david.result or
um if you want to check out my fitness
pages at endeavour life
and uh they're the best places to find
me i give loads of free information out
on endeavor life
and um it's a little bit less completely
fitness focused
on my personal page you know usually
talking about a bunch of stuff that we
talked about today actually
and it's generally what's going on in
life it's very much a personal
personal thing you know you never know
what you're gonna get
i like it man look david today's been
really cool everyone that's listening if
you've got any questions comments or
feedback you know where to go
get at me at chriswell x wherever you
follow me or leave the comments on
youtube or
do whatever you want leave your comment
to david and it'll take him a couple
years and he might end up getting back
to you
now david bro thank you so much for your
time
grace have a nice day man i'll speak to
[Music]
you